i've yet to meet malcolm oh well he's a
little baby yeah i know
i but i mean it's funny it's so cute to
hear you say his name like he's a person
he is a person i know but it's so funny
i keep going i keep going to parties and
bus stops and stuff and i don't see
malcolm coming along yeah yeah i think
like i haven't run into him i've been
seeing malcolm at phil rosenthal's i
don't know why he wasn't at the big
at the big pizza
pizza oven
pizza con 22. i think andy richter said
this once he said because he had uh
his daughter mercy before i had kids and
he said
man it sure makes your life
before looked like it was in black and
white he likened it i was kind of like
what's it like and he said it's like the
black and white uh movie wizard of oz
and then she opens the door and it's
color he said that's how much it and he
said it sure does make your life before
look pretty silly when a human being
shows up so that's really funny yeah
that's really sweet it does yeah that's
an interesting it does
man i
you know when you watch a movie with
someone who hasn't seen the movie before
yep that's what it feels like with
malcolm like when i'm out with him
i'm like oh the world's great because
i'm seeing it sorted through his eyes
right and he's looking up like trees and
[ __ ]
malcolm will lay on his back on a
blanket in the backyard and just like
kick his arms and legs squealing because
he sees trees in the sky right and i
never cared about any of that [ __ ]
outside stuff
never cared no i really didn't i really
didn't
not a nature guy
let alone nature i bet i was not a
backyard guy uh uh in i'm an endorsement
and so yeah you are a rugged
left you're a rugged endorsement right
right you're the nick offerman of the
indoors yeah who can't do a single thing
with his hands couldn't shuffle a deck
of cards or i could but if i wouldn't
want to know the watch
not because i'm cheating but i don't
know how to shuffle
uh but man he just uh
and i love i mean he's my son and i love
him so much but also like i just
i'm fascinated by him yeah i love
watching him see the world right and
seeing what like sounds what sounds
images lights volume levels he make him
laugh and then times where he gives
these looks like jesus not like crying
just kind of like can you not
yeah well you have that great
i'll get like too loud and too high in
his ear like huh and he's like okay all
right all right easy dingbat
[Laughter]
jilly take
and i still am ambitious and i still
want to do things but it's just
that's still there but i'm like
uh if he's good i'm good yes
and i i liked that um i don't know
almost lessening of the ego or ego
deflation of
just
oh i still have a big ego oh oh no trust
me
so do i but when my ego's deflated it's
still insane i'm still stalling i mean
sometimes i lean down i go malcolm you
know what your last name is
[ __ ] famous
is it true that you're constantly
handing uh malcolm eight by tens of
yourself oh yeah you know what i would
like to he's sort of one time i walked
in the room and just because he's
learning his hand he's just learning he
has hands and he's just always like it's
like he's a shifty guy lying on the
stand you know he's like i'm like you
keep gripping one hand and the other
hand back and forth yeah these little
pudgy ass hands
um that look like quiche and he's like
uh but he banged them together when i
walked in i was like ooh i wonder if i
could get him and just train him to do
that every time i entered the room yeah
hey i tried with my kids um
you know it was great with uh
mike sweeney warm up your kids i tipped
my legs
when my kids were born the minute they
came out i had mike sweeney uh
sort of work with you know work the
crowd yeah for 10 minutes and so they
knew that i was a big deal um
i don't know why that just reminded me
of when we first started doing the late
night show in 93 we knew nothing about
what we were doing we had all these
crazy ideas and all these grand schemes
but in terms of the nuts and bolts of
how you run a late night show we didn't
know anything and we didn't know that
you need a warm up guy oh no so we was
anyone helping you here's what happened
no actually so we didn't know that we
needed a warm-up guy and then someone
said oh we need a warm-up guy and we
said well who does warm-up on letterman
and they said well the announcer does it
and for johnny carson
the announcer ed mcmahon did it and so
we thought right the announcer so we had
hired this announcer very nice guy joel
goddard who had a terrific voice and
he'd be like it's conan and o'brien and
then we started putting him in sketches
but he was um a straight voiceover
announcer guy who literally his whole
you know his career had been
stay tuned for more
you know uh this brought to you by chevy
trucks he reliable chevy trucks that's
all he had done and so we handed him a
microphone someone handed him a
microphone i was of course busy just
trying to
not wet myself and so um we were busy
with how can we
premiere this show and not get killed
and how can we survive
so we just sent him out and i remembered
walking out to befuddled crowds for a
while
and not kind of understanding what was
going on and then once i was putting my
tie on and god love you joel it was
great but i heard him doing the warm-up
and he was saying
then conan went off to harvard where he
studied the history and literature of
america specializing
in flannery o'connor and faulkner's work
in the deep south
part of the southern literary movement
he graduated magnum [ __ ]
laude aren't you
born with every advantage
you know it was the last thing in the
world you would want to tell an audience
about a comedian yeah
conan is uh so let's get a lot of energy
up let's get a lot of energy for a man
who's read a lot of books you're in town
for one day you're in town for one day
and you've come to a taping and it was
just
he joined the
acapella group
yeah four white male singing group
specializing in singing and round before
i bring them out let me tell you i have
felt conan's hands and they are really
soft never a day's honest work
o'brien claims he's never actually seen
anyone do physical labor because his pot
hair the latin term for father told him
it should be avoided
let's bring him out now with a lot of
energy
[Laughter]
that's a true story